Superman frames Batman for murder and we
get to see DC's God killer in this video
how's that for an intro so this is
Batman's Superman world's finest and I
love this comic that DC has going right
now so what this does is this basically
opens up with Batman and Superman
alongside Robin and Jimmy Olsen
investigating the murder of Simon stag
now Simon stag just one of these guys
where he's like a major criminal but he
does have a lot of involvement and a lot
of personal goings-on with a guy by the
name of Rex Mason now Rex Mason is a
name that some of you all may recall but
for individuals who don't know who Rex
Mason is what's so cool about this comic
and it's one of the reasons why I love
it so much is that DC just kind of gives
us a short-handed explanation which is
great because I don't have to go and
read secret Origins from the 1980s so
the thing about Rex Mason and and really
the explanation that's given here which
really kind of comes by way of Superman
and Jimmy Olsen because Jimmy's not
really familiar with it what he
basically says is that some time ago Rex
Mason was really like an adventurer and
kind of like half an archaeologist so
think of him as being very similar to
like an Indiana Jones type character but
he ended up falling in love with the
daughter of Simon Stag and so Simon
Stagg arranged to have Rex Mason killed
now where things went nuts here right
and the way it's explained I think is
actually better than the way they
explained it in the old secret origin
stories is that stag promised Mason
Millions to unearth an artifact called
the orb of raw from the Lost Pyramid of
the Pharaoh Octan which a lot of you
guys already know is based on black
Adam's Mythos now Java who's basically
the henchman of Simon Stagg basically
he's the guy that kills people whenever
Simon's dad doesn't want to get his
hands dirty right the Java went inside
and that Rex Mason basically learned the
secrets of the orb itself that it had
been fashioned from a mysterious
radioactive meteor buried somewhere in
the heart of the pyramid and the Java
didn't really care about any of that he
simply just wanted to please his master
and so he threw Mason deeper into the
pyramid and unknowingly dangerously near
the media here Mason said he could feel
the radiation tearing the muscle off his
bones smell his flesh crackling and
burning certain he was doomed he passed
out again from the pain and when he
awoke he had wished he had died because
he was so physically just screwed up now
here's the thing about this and this is
the part that it doesn't really explain
all that well here in the aftermath of
this he's been a long time trying to get
himself sorted back out once he was able
to reconstitute himself effectively he
basically became metamorpho right the
guy who could adapt his body to
virtually any element in existence now
metamorpho is one of these characters
he's like the absorbing man Crusher
Creole and Marvel Comics right he's
incredibly powerful but painfully
underutilized right like metamorpho is a
guy who could kill the DC Universe and
it would be believable the cool thing
about metamorpho is that this guy's been
able to hold his own against the Justice
League I don't know how many times but
the big question people have here is who
killed Simon Stagg now like I said the
Batman Superman team is splitting the
two groups so you've got Batman and
Robin who are doing their thing and they
they need no introduction and then you
have Superman and Jimmy Olsen now one of
the cool things about this is this comic
is a great reference to Superman's pal
Jimmy Olsen which for those of you guys
who don't know kind of a little bit of
History here Superman busts onto the
scenes in the 1930s right so over the
course of the next 20 years or so it was
just super boy and Superman and that was
it then more weissinger becomes the
editor of Superman and his role or his
uh kind of task is add something new
every six months right so you get
Supergirl you get bevel the super
monkeys tricky the super cat comment the
super horse so on and so forth one of
the comics or really a couple Comics
that you got out of this is you got a
Lois Lane comic and then you got a
Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen comic those
Comics sold like gangbusters you
wouldn't think they would but DC could
not keep those things in stock it was
crazy how popular they were but of
course Jimmy Olsen kind of following
Superman along behind this whole thing
you've got them operating as reporters
investigating on a more journalistic
side and then Batman and Robin
investigating in their own capacity the
biggest issue here right the major major
issue that comes out of this is you end
up having this realization from both
Jimmy Olsen and Superman these little
Clues and things that they find all seem
to point to the idea that Bruce Wayne
killed metamorpho and so the biggest
thing that they have to contend with is
what do they do with this information do
they keep it Hush Hush or do they bring
it to light now the reality here is that
working as reporters they are beholden
to a kind of journalistic Integrity
something that's painfully lacking in
2023 but the reality here is that they
have to basically publish it they take
it to Perry white and Perry white
basically tells them we're going to run
this article either we can run it with
you or without you but there's no way we
cannot run an article and inform the
public that Bruce Wayne is seemingly
behind this now the kicker is that when
the information comes to Light Bruce
Wayne is basically arrested now there's
two reasons why this happens right the
first part is the one we just discussed
journalistic Integrity but the second
part is because it's a way to basically
lure the actual killer into a false
sense of security because if the Killer
is out therein believes that they've
captured the person who's committed the
crime that in turn they just kind of
feel compelled to just continue on and
do their own thing the alternative to
this is that Killers want to be caught
and so this guy would actually escalate
his crimes in an effort to demonstrate
that it's not Bruce Wayne that they have
the wrong guy right it just kind of
depends on the motivation and whatever
profile they have but what goes on here
this is one of the cool things right
what goes on here is you end up
switching over to metamorpho who
basically goes after like this small
time guy and one of the funny things
about this is that it's him kind of
trying to do superhero stuff as well as
metamorpho can do but the thing about
this is that with you know kind of
jumping over to Batman where you have
metamorpho who takes out the small time
guy Batman is incensed at Superman right
like bro like you frame me for murder
man like what's the deal and the funny
thing here is that Superman's like look
there's only so much I can do not even
Superman can just exonerate you and even
Superman himself says look I know that
you're not the one who committed this
crime but the reality here is there's no
way that Clark Kent can know that no
conceivable way he could know all he
could do is quote unquote piece together
the evidence and unless the evidence
somehow indicates you're not involved
Clark Kent cannot cook the books and
just start fabricating documentation to
show that you're innocent so of course
Batman's on house arrest
so that kind of has him pissed off a
little bit but of course Batman being
Batman he doesn't actually have to go
anywhere to be effective right I mean he
has the entirety of the internet at his
disposal and his intellect right the guy
can just solve a crime while he's making
Corn Flakes and so one of the things
that happens here and initially it seems
throw away one of the things that
happens here is Oliver Queen hits up
Batman and says hey Bruce I have an idea
and I'm curious to see if you would be
involved and the question that Bruce has
is okay like what's this idea that you
have and he says I'm looking at
basically working on an artificial
intelligence project and I'm curious to
see if you would be interested now
here's the kicker to this Bruce Wayne
really just kind of sits back in his
chair for a second kind of analyzes
everything and then says I'll get back
right so like right off the bat the
wheels are turn it now anybody who's
familiar with Oliver Queen with the
green arrow knows right off the bat this
is fishy but you would only pick up on
it if you've been reading green arrow
for quite some time even I didn't notice
what was going on initially right like
the clues are there if you know what to
look for not only that because of the
fact that Batman can't actually operate
with anything you basically have like a
Robin Superman team up Robin is riding
on Superman's back
but with the two of them accessing the
information Batman gave them what he
basically did is provide them with a
list of metamorphose Rogues right
there's various villains the people that
intentionally go for him and so what
metamorpho appears to be doing is
targeting each one of these individuals
but he's moving in a linear Direction
and so that leads them to believe that
he's basically heading south so what
they end up doing is following this
Trail and ultimately find themselves in
this kind of war-torn territory where
you have like metamorpho facing off
against just this crazy dictator type
guy and for the most part he's taken out
pretty quickly what ends up happening if
Superman stops the sky deadness tracks
and then you switch back over to Batman
and what happens is Batman is getting a
hold of Ted Court over at cord
Industries right the original Blue
Beetle or at least the the most popular
version of Blue Beetle before Jaime
Reyes and as they're all talking things
just seem a little off and a little
strange right Batman just keeps getting
this idea that something's not quite
right and so what he does is he calls
Superman and he says I had a
conversation with Oliver Queen yesterday
right like Oliver Queen he's a human
rights Advocate right this guy is all
about like the human element this guy
hit me up and wants to work on some kind
of like technology this design in part
to supplant human decision making right
the guy who advocates for human activity
more than anything else is basically
working on AI Oliver Queen would never
do that the same thing's going on with
Ted court right something's off and so
what Bruce Wayne does is he says okay
like what I need you to do is I'm
currently here at the funeral for Simon
Stagg scan the area and see if
anything's off Superman of course having
x-ray vision and being Superman from
however far away he is scans the whole
area and realizes that what's inside the
head of Simon stag is not a human brain
it's a computerized brain it's highly
Advanced but it's a computerized brain
so in turn what they do is putting two
and two together the weirdness and the
strangeness of Oliver Queen the fact
that Simon stag was replaced with
basically a robot and metamorpho kind of
along for the ride which admittedly a
Batman Superman and metamorpho Team Up
Is Awesome
they come to this realization that
someone is out there replacing
billionaires with robots now this is
where we get to the god Killer part of
the story and this is the thing it never
occurred to me to do this it never
occurred to me to do this and I'm kind
of astounded that it took DC this long
to come up with it but the fact that
they did it's amazing as they're going
through and they're doing all this
research and all this investigation
right Batman says digging into all their
finances right these individuals these
billionaires right enormous sums of
money are subtly being funneled to one
offshore account and when metamorpho
asks who's the account owned by the
response of Batman Professor Anthony Ivo
now anybody who knows anything about
Professor Ivo will tell you this is the
guy that made Amazon is a robot that can
copy the powers of anybody in the
Justice League right so what's going on
here is a guy that can duplicate Powers
is replacing people with robots so of
course they end up basically following
the offshore count right they eventually
get to its location which is effectively
the modern or at least the updated
location of where Dr Anthony Ivo
operates and as they're walking through
really Superman and Robin because again
Batman's still on house arrest you can't
just leave right so as they're walking
through they start to see like all these
different robots that are partially
finished right that aren't completely
done and so the Superman kind of Muses
to himself and says that these robots
are half finished because they probably
stop being useful to Ivo once Bruce
Wayne became a murder suspect and that's
when Ivo chimes in and says correct
Superman right and he says it seems that
you're on to me the doppelgangers
steering money my way mine yes they're
mine well they're essentially mine and
so where you have Superman that kind of
keeps goading him into talking he says
keep talking Ivo confession is good for
the soul your marionettes are not a
threat to me and the response of Ivo is
oh I know they're for the boy right like
these robots are all for the boy the
response of Ivo is I have something
grander planned for you Superman I've
got something far more useful planned
for you so Batman who effectively snuck
out right like he literally jumped out
the window of his room and snuck out
without his parents not basically with
metamorpho they're just kind of like
going through and investigating the
other half of this equation but as
they're going through and investigating
they find out that Ivo is literally just
kind of like killing and then cloning
people in the form of robots right he's
literally getting rid of The Originals
and replacing them with robots so he
never has to worry about The Originals
coming back back and then people asking
questions why there's like two Simon
Stags running around and so in the midst
of all this the different robots make
their way towards Robin but where he
asks Superman for help Superman suddenly
starts to get a little off kilter right
things seem a little strange his
strength sort of starts to move away
right a source to disappear weakness
starts setting in and so that's when Ivo
starts to commentate and he says when I
started this whole process I thought
about just bringing back Amazo and
having a Mazo do its thing but then the
question became why stop there why just
stop with copying the bodies of
billionaires and replacing them with
robots or bringing back a meso and doing
the Amazo thing what if I could take the
powers of metamorpho and combine them
with the powers of Amazo so then I would
have a robot that could not only copy
the powers of the Justice League but any
element in existence and so what we're
introduced to is ultramorpho the god
killer this is a robot that can copy any
element and any power which can include
green Kryptonite so what does Superman
do against an enemy that can not only
turn into green Kryptonite but beat the
crap out of him with his own strength
while he does it we'll find out in the
next video with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching Cliffhangers and I
will catch you all later peace